so anytime I anytime I get into a
subject like this I'm always reminded by
folks in the comment section that I'm
not a theologian I'm not a philosopher
I'm not a scientist and thus I'm not
qualified to discuss these sorts of
matters and it's true that I am I am
none of those things
however I do reject the idea that you
have to be a specialist in order to
think about and talk about the deeper
questions in life I think that's a very
sad way to to view life and to go about
life you know to view it as something
that can only be discussed by highly
qualified academics and the rest of us
just have to sort of walk about our
merry way and never think about these
things that that's not how I see it I I
think that even normal people like
myself and you can and should have these
discussions so so here goes
I've always thought that two of the best
arguments for the existence of God
are these the argument from
consciousness and the argument from
morality now I don't know if they are
the best to me they're the best they are
to me the most compelling so they're so
compelling that even if every other
argument for God was disproven which
which wouldn't happen but even if it did
happen I would still think that a belief
in God is the most rational thing based
on these two arguments now I'm not gonna
get into the whole argument from
consciousness thing it's I think it's
yeah it's familiar enough to most people
who've who've thought about these
matters in essence you know if God does
not exist then only physical matter and
physical processes exist only the
physical world exists but if that's the
case how could matter by chance without
design thought intention assemble itself
in such a way as to create consciousness
how do you get love from dust even even
with you start with dust even if you add
billions and billions of years on top of
it how does it ever become love what
about what about anger happiness empathy
and so on how does a material thing
derived from material and nothing more
develop abstract ideas no other animal
can do this nothing else on earth can
have abstract ideas dolphins are very
intelligent aquatic animals but even the
most intelligent dolphin cannot think
about the idea of say freedom much less
can a dolphin
desire freedom you know much less can
the dolphin look at itself and say I'm a
dolphin I am me but I wish I were more
than me
you know dolphin can't do that but if
there is no God then this is kind of the
entire story of mankind
my man desiring to be free from himself
to be more than what he is more than
material right that it's a very sad
terrible story there's no God you have
these these biological creatures which
are ourselves that have developed
somehow this desire to not to be more
than us but how could material develop a
desire to be more than material and
again why hasn't any other material
developed that desire why isn't any
other material developed that capacity
most of all how could a totally physical
thing originating from Stardust become
aware of itself that's the trickiest
thing for atheists I think they they
might say that well the brain is a
computer and so all the things I
mentioned love empathy anger sadness so
on are just functions of the you know
come fancy computer system that we got
in our heads but of course there's
already a problem with that argument
because computers are designed designed
we should say by humans who have the
capacity to design things like computers
because of their consciousness so an
atheist who discounts God by saying well
the brain is just a computer might as
well discount God by saying well the
human body is just like a sculpture
yeah and find me a sculpture that
sculpted itself find me a a computer
that built itself but even more to the
point we are aware of ourselves so it's
not just awareness that the atheists
have to explain but self-awareness
how could a clump of dust however
evolved ever come to know itself as a
clump of dust and why is it that no
other form of matter or assemblage of
matter has ever developed this ability
and why isn't there any computer even
the most come advanced computer in the
world
um does not know itself as a computer so
if this is a function of a computer
system in our heads then why can't other
computers demonstrate the same ability
outside of science fiction novels so
that's one argument I just said I'm not
gonna get into it then I did the other
argument is the argument from morality
and as that argument goes we know that
objective morality exists and objective
morality cannot exist without a
transcendent source there can be no
transcendent source for morality without
God who is that source thus God exists
now I think that's a compelling argument
personally an atheist can go to general
directions with that argument
maybe there are other direction this is
all based on what I've you know what
I've encountered from a theist it seems
to me that an atheist will generally go
to directions that argument he can argue
that objective morality does not exist
morality is subjective it's relative so
that's moral relativism of course or he
can argue that objective morality does
exist but it has some other source that
isn't God now here's the interesting
thing I've noticed it seems that modern
atheists and secular people are not as
likely to be a vowed relativists that is
explicit pronounced moral relativists
that seems to be kind of not as
fashionable among atheists and secular
people as it used to be it's not like it
wasn't a 19th century what what is more
common now what's most common I think is
a kind of secular objective morality
that often expresses itself as a
half-baked relativism it's very confused
you know so the average person in in in
our culture is very fond of saying
things like this is my truth or don't
impose your morality on me your morality
talking about morality as if it's a
thing that you can own and you have your
very own version of it or they'll say
just do what makes
you happy you know those kinds of things
and they'll say this especially when
they when their own actions are
challenged or when something that they
personally find acceptable is criticized
but often these very same people will
condemn things like racism rape slavery
pollution and do so by appealing very
forcefully to some objective standard
condemning the wrongdoer for breaking
some kind of moral code that apparently
we're all supposed to abide by so in
practice I would say the average secular
person is
really neither a moral absolutist nor a
relativist but kind of a mix which by
definition makes them a relativist yet
few people seem to want to embrace moral
relativism the way that Richard Dawkins
does Dawkins who famously said that a
bit of quote mild pedophilia isn't so
bad if it happened a long time ago
because the moral standards were
different back then which is a
consistent morally relativistic position
to hold even though it's also horrifying
most secular people it seems don't go
that far they try to maintain the
appearances at least of an objective
morality even if they abandon the
objective you know that argument
whenever it suits them to abandon it now
when an atheist
and I keep saying atheist or secular
person by the way so understand that I
mean avowed atheists as well as the
average person in society who isn't
necessarily settled on the god question
but lives and operates as if there isn't
a God so it's kind of a de-facto atheist
I'm calling them all atheists for the
sake of this discussion so anyway when
an atheist tries to argue for objective
morality
it seems the argument hinges almost
always on utilitarian grounds
that's almost always what it seems to
come down to now there is another theory
there's kind of a platonic theory of
morality as an objective thing that
exists in the abstract just kind of
floating out there in the ether and I
think that's serious basically
unintelligible so I'm not going to focus
on it then a third option of course is
the Darwinian idea of morality as a
product of evolution humans evolved a
moral sense because it helps us live
together as people in a in a cohesive
society but this is still moral
relativism it's not really objective
morality because in this view morality
is no more significant than opposable
thumbs
it's just a thing that developed
biologically to make our lives easier
so we have opposable thumbs and
opposable thumbs are helpful but nobody
would say that we have some kind of
obligation to use our thumbs nobody
would say that they said you have your
thumbs it's great you have nobody says
you must use your thumbs you have to use
them yet morality is all about
obligation it's all about what you know
you ought to do such-and-such you ought
not do such-and-such so morality is all
about so in evolved morality might
partly explain how we got to this point
without completely annihilating
ourselves
um only partially annihilating ourselves
but it doesn't explain why in the world
I should actually act according to it
now
that that's what it doesn't explain so
evolved morality explains how we got
here but now that we're here it doesn't
explain why I should actually abide by
this thing anymore than explains why I
would have some sort of obligation to
use my thumbs throughout the day what if
I don't want to use them I won't use
them so that leaves us with the third
option for atheists
something like what Sam Harris argues
for he says that morality is morality is
is basically that which brings about
human flourishing a morally right action
is an action that brings the greatest
good you know to the greatest number of
people I was also I was listening to a
debate with a moral philosopher teaches
philosophy at Yale I believe shelly
kagan
um and he defined morality very simply
as as this he said morally wrong action
is action that that hurts someone or
fails to help them and morally right
action is action that helps someone or
refrains from hurting them
now I think this definition works pretty
well with sam Harris's definition and I
think they both fail to provide any
basis at all for objective morality and
here's why first of all two Kagan's
point it's true that it hurts someone
when I steal their car
but the question is not whether a thing
hurts someone the question is why should
I care that I hurt someone why shouldn't
I hurt someone
so you haven't gotten to the ought but
you have to get to the OTT because
that's the whole point
second to Harris's point it's true that
slavery does not lead to the human
flourishing of slaves
but why should I care about the slaves
and who says that slaves are supposed to
flourish and take the United States in
the early 19th century most citizens of
the country weren't slaves what if it
could have been argued that slavery
helped the greatest number in that
environment flourish wouldn't that make
it morally right by this standard on the
atheistic view why in the world should
the greatest number sacrifice their own
comfort for the sake of the minority but
so often in practice that's what--that's
that that is what morality requires
that's often when morality you know
comes into into focus and comes most
into play
is when a person in position of power
has to make a sacrifice for someone who
doesn't have power or when the majority
has to sacrifice for the minority that's
really when you get to you know that
that's when moral claims are the most
relevant
but it seems like on the atheistic view
there's just no scenario where that
should ever happen
third it seems that in order to
establish an objective moral standard
for human beings
you have to first establish that human
beings themselves possessed some kind of
moral worth or moral value themselves so
the only way to argue that I should
steal kill enslave etc is to first argue
that the people who would be hurt by
such actions have themselves moral worth
and unless you're a radical vegan or
environmentalist you have to argue that
they have more moral worth than say a
squirrel or a cockroach if we can agree
that it's a greater evil to kill a child
than a cockroach you have to explain
what actually makes the child more
valuable objectively not just what makes
him more valuable to me but what makes
him objectively more valuable so that
even if I didn't recognize his moral
worth he would still have it
so you have to explain what makes them
more valuable what makes life in general
valuable and then what creates this kind
of high right hierarchy
it seems that atheist arguments for
morality all of them sort of start by
assuming the moral value of human beings
without explaining how they arrived at
that assumption
it seems to me that if human beings are
only a random assemblage of matter then
they have no claim no objective claim to
being any more important than any other
kind of matter in the atheistic view we
are we are all tiny little clumps of
stuff wandering around on a tiny speck
called Earth which itself is hurtling
through the endless abyss of space and
soon in the blink of an eye from the
cosmic view we're gonna fade back into
the nothingness from whence we came
so if that's the case you would have a
hard time convincing me that my own life
matters but someone else's why
just like that they're going to be gone
anyway
if I could zoom out and see the earth
you know from it from another solar
system none of us would matter at all
we're all just little Ansari no we're
all just little ants on this little ball
that's spinning around in space who
cares
why should I care about them
and again from the from the cosmic
standpoint soon enough the entire earth
itself will be destroyed so why does it
matter now you can point out that I do
care about other people's lives even
though I'm saying all of this you can
point out that life is easier for all of
us most of the time if we act like we
care about other people's lives but you
haven't explained why I have some sort
of objective duty to care about other
people because a duty by definition is
something given to us
um assigned to us right that's what a
duty is which is why anytime anyone says
to you do this or don't do that you can
all you always have the instinct to
respond says who
anytime someone tells you not to do
something or to do something you always
want to know by what authority are they
telling you that
so the question to atheists again when
it comes to morality is says who
fourth point Kagan in that same debate
he he grapples with this question he
says that well if every commandment
needs a commander if every requirement
needs a require er then the commander
and the require er would be us society
it's wrong to kill rape steal etc
because we all say so that's what makes
it wrong it is the consensus of a
civilized society
is an obvious and very significant
problem here if morality is decided by
democratic consensus on what basis can
we condemn historical slavery
considering that almost everyone in the
world for thousands of years thought
that slavery was fine in fact how can
the minority I go back to this point
again how can the minority ever make a
moral criticism of the majority if
morality is decided by majority
consensus how can a person ever claim
that something most people do or most
people support is wrong how could you go
to a fundamentalist Muslim country and
say that it's wrong to execute
homosexuals when everyone there thinks
it's right
fifth point every atheistic system of
morality that I've ever encountered
seems to completely ignore the moral
implications of of our private actions
and our private thoughts and this isn't
a point that that I hear even even
Christians when they're arguing this you
know about objective morality and
everything I don't often hear them bring
this point up
I mean everything I've said so far you
know you could William Lane Craig or
someone like that has already made these
points way better than I've made them so
it's like you don't even need to listen
to anything I've just said just listen
to him um but now this next part I don't
I unless I missed it I don't often hear
this point brought up so maybe it's a
bad argument that I'm about to make but
to me it's it's just something I think
about and and I haven't heard a theist
really address it so I'm gonna go with
it so you you have the issue of private
actions and private thoughts okay if if
morality is only what helps people and
immorality is only what hurts people
well again you haven't explained why I
should care about hurting or helping
people or why people are worth helping
or why they're so valuable that I
shouldn't hurt them but even putting all
that aside what about the private and
interior lives of people
what about everything that goes on
inside me is all of that outside of the
moral framework entirely is it
completely morally irrelevant what I
think
now you may say that it is okay well
let's take some extreme examples extreme
though not at all
though not at all you know fantastical
so take for instance a person who
indulges in rape fantasies in his head
person who doesn't just have a thought
pop into his head about raping someone
but actually indulges the thought and
enjoys thinking about it or take a man
who indulges in pedophilic fantasies
take even a man who watches child
pornography and I know there you might
argue that watching child pornography is
wrong because you are in some ways
supporting the child porn industry which
is true so fine but let's just say
hypothetically you got a man who
stumbles across a DVD lying on the
street filled with child porn it
stumbled across a laptop that's got a
bunch of child porn downloaded on it and
so he watches it now you probably in
Steven as an atheist I think you would
instinctively say that he's wrong for
watching
but why it's not hurting anybody people
were hurt in the production of that
pornography but that's already happened
he isn't lending any material support to
it whatsoever
he isn't practically adding to the
misery of the victims so why is it wrong
and what about the pedophilic fantasies
which he engages with in his mind or the
man with the rape fantasies or a woman
who sits around all day dreaming of all
the violent things she'd like to do to
the people that she hates
again I think instinctively you'd say
that these thoughts are wrong and it's
wrong to indulge those thoughts but on
what basis it's not hurting anyone an
atheistic morality seems always I mean
there's a million versions of it but it
always basically comes down to don't
hurt people
sixth point you might try to argue that
it isn't wrong to indulge in hateful
thoughts or violent thoughts or
pedophilic thoughts or whatever if
you're an atheist and I guess you'd have
to say that even if you don't fully
believe it yourself I think
instinctively and you instinctively you
know that these thoughts are wrong
but if you're forced to engage with this
argument I assume to probably say well
you know it's not really wrong
there's another problem
why would a person feel guilty for those
thoughts where does the guilt come from
now if you've ever had a very hateful
thought about someone if you've ever had
someone that you really hate and and you
had a thought where you wish harm to
fall upon them right see if you've ever
had that thought in your head then
you've probably felt guilty for that
thought
but why it seems that guilt in such a
circumstance is a biological anomaly in
the atheistic view anyway because you
didn't hurt anyone with your thoughts
you didn't do anything to society nobody
knows about it nobody's affected by it
at all it's just you and your thoughts
and according to atheist that's it I
mean you're completely alone with your
thoughts nobody else knows has no effect
on anybody
so why would guilt ever come into play
now you might say that it's a biological
response but a biological response to
what if morality is all about evolution
we're all about what society says we're
all about what hurts people or any other
atheist definition of the term then how
in the world and why in the world did
guilt for thoughts ever arise doesn't
hurt anyone doesn't affect society so
why is the guilt there
I think that's it you know centralising
question for atheists because you have
not only do you have to explain to go to
the first thing I mentioned you have to
explain where do these abstract concepts
come up you know like an abstract idea
where did that how did we develop that
ability but then we have the a guilt for
an abstract idea and where did that come
from
here's the point
I think atheists will say that
I I think what it comes down to it most
a the average is if they're being honest
and if they're just you know speaking
from their heart I think that they will
instinctively as I said they will
distinctively say that the person who
indulges in hateful thoughts is doing
something just as they will call the man
with the child porn immoral they'll say
that he's doing something a more right
just as they'll condemn slavery even
when the slavery benefits most people in
society just as they'll call homophobia
wrong even when most people in a society
have agreed that it's right just as
they'll probably condemn the Aztecs who
engaged in human sacrifice on an
unprecedented scale and most people were
not sacrificed and the non sacrifice
people considered the sacrifices to be
something that helped them flourish yet
I think a theist would would would
probably condemn that just as they'll
certainly condemned the Nazis even
though only a minority were herded into
camps and everyone else could have lived
prosperously under Nazi rule if it
weren't for Hitler's world domination
goals and he hadn't done all that then
things probably would have worked out
okay for the rest of the Germans yet
atheist would condemn that as wrong just
as most of them presumably will would
condemn the systematic extermination of
the mentally ill and criminals even
though the existence of those types of
people in some ways detracts from the
pleasure and well-being of everyone else
and also they're the lives of those
people by the atheistic by the atheistic
view could not possibly have as much
value as the life of a healthy and
law-abiding person
yet
that's the stance that most
atheist people seem to take
why
why won't these atheists and these
secular people just embrace moral
relativism and admit that nothing is
objectively immoral there are things
that for collective convenience we
should outlaw but but doesn't mean that
they're actually wrong in some objective
way
why won't most of them take that view
it's because the objective nature of
morality is clearly apparent to everyone
even Richard Dawkins the avowed
relativist
now keep in mind the the the qualifier
that he put on his statement about well
pedophilia was okay back when everyone
thought it was okay that's moral
relativism but even then he says mild
pedophilia he puts that really weird
qualifier on it of ultra mild pedophilia
was okay
but beyond that that wasn't okay so he
felt the need to stipulate mild even as
he tears down the moral law he can't
bring himself to tear it all the way
down
so it's clear to me
that everyone whether they admit it or
not looks at the moral code as a thing
that exists as a as a real objective
thing as a thing we ought to follow as a
thing that we live under as a thing that
we should live according to as a thing
that would still be there intact even if
nobody in the world recognized as a
thing that says that slavery is wrong
and so slavery will always be wrong even
if tomorrow everyone in the world thinks
it's ok it's still wrong
seems like basically everyone views
morality in that light they view it in a
word as a transcendent thing
but there is nothing transcendent in a
purely material world which to me tells
us that we are not living in a purely
material world
think
objective morality is pretty good
evidence for the existence of God
got that in exactly 30 minutes I feel
pretty good about that as well thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed